brumeux,
garde les yeux ouverts pour les fils là-bas,
Dorothy ouais,
je le ferai aussi,
plus on est de fous, plus nous sommes meilleurs, oui,
comme là-bas, c'est comme si tu en voulais plus là-bas,
d'accord, ça a l'air vraiment rouge, c'est
comme si c'était comme euh, pas un  un peu de couleur
sur ça qui frappe ici, on m'a donné
un peu la caméra
pour cette merde,
quelque part là-dedans, je
ne vois pas l'ombre, n'est-ce pas, non non non
non, je l'ai dit à notre live de 14 heures,
d'accord, je l'ai compris,
allons-y  commence par installer les autres
nuages ​​​​gonflés comme ça
non tu ne vois plus les arbres non non
non mais commençons par là alors ok ok
laisse-lui quelques secondes
je veux dire ce que nous pourrions faire si nous pouvions trouver
un arbre aux couleurs vives qui est  il
se dresse
un peu plus haut que
toute autre chose
euh. Entourez-le dans un rayon d'environ 50 mètres.
Entourez-le,
il faudrait que ce soit quelqu'un assis
sur une crête ou quelque chose comme ça pour que nous puissions voir l'arrière-
plan qui revient en arrière,
nous prendrons des arbres.  tout autour, ouais
ouais, je ne pense pas que les couleurs
dépassent vraiment les autres
maintenant,
peut-être qu'il y a comme une crête ou
quelque chose comme ça, eh
bien, je veux dire, voilà, nous
arrivons à de petits boutons.  ici avec quelques
couleurs et je pourrais faire un
zoom légèrement plus important, euh ouais, un peu
plus de téléobjectif en quelque sorte voler autour d'
eux
avec un appareil photo qui le regarde, vous savez,
trois heures avant ou neuf heures
pendant que nous volons  autour, c'est
un peu plus rouge sur le côté droit,
n'est-ce pas, je vais tourner à droite
ici Peter, ok, vas-y, d'accord,
nous avons une couleur légèrement meilleure sur le
ciel, comme pour le trajet  aussi bien ouais
tu vois ce bouton presque au centre
on va rester juste sur le
côté droit ça ressemble à ce que tu veux
ok d'accord
étranger
ouais on a perdu un peu de couleur tout droit
maintenant d'
accord là c'est encore
ok  arrêtons-nous un instant, nous allons nous
aligner sur ces arbres, d'accord,
tournons à droite ouais, nous allons garder une
distance pour vous, vous pouvez globalement ralentir
comme vous pouvez ralentir car vous pouvez le rendre
étranger,
je ne suis pas sûr  Je suis sur cette couleur de base
là,
c'est à droite ici
ouais pourquoi Circle et plus lentement à
droite, nous arrivons à droite pour ses ombres
quand nous arrivons de ce côté du virage
ouais nous sommes sous le vent,
nous allons  fais juste ce que tu peux faire ouais
c'est assez large ouais c'est bien ouais faisons
juste un autre tour ouais est-ce que
ça va pour toi Peter ouais oui bonne
affaire pas toi [ __ ]
étranger
prends les arbres autour de nous
hein qu'est-ce que
ça va trop vite ouais je sais  c'est
mec oh je ne pensais pas que tu
te tirais une balle non non non très bien ici s'il te plaît
joue attends
je devrais y aller comme ça
ouais chaque instant de l'autre regarde de l'
autre côté ouais il
a été à quelques mètres
ouais il est droit au soleil
Je vais ramasser cette petite partie de
la rivière ouais,
c'est quoi ta petite maison là-bas ou
quelque chose comme ça dans la cascade ou quelque
chose de blanc entre les deux, je ne
m'inquiète pas trop d'une maison ici,
ramasse-la aussi loin que les gens ne le font pas
attention, ils sont heureux d'entendre un bruit, je
pense que j'avais un peu chaud là-bas, à moins qu'ils ne
soient en train de chasser,
ils chassaient, ils
étaient ici pour chasser un hélicoptère
ouais
Chopper de toute façon
et puis après, si vous pouvez juste faire
un suivi à la rivière, tout va bien  nous
sommes là depuis les machines à sous, ne trichez pas
juste à droite ouais, il va
tirer tout de suite ouais, suivez les trois hommes
étrangers,
vous ne voyez pas, il fait trop sombre
si vous voulez notre chemin,
quoi ouais, revenez en arrière
non je  je pense qu'il y en aura beaucoup plus euh tu
sais que la caméra regardera dans l'
ombre, c'est bien mieux que les petits
moniteurs là-bas
oh il y a un lac là-bas je vais
courir dans un lac oh ouais
je savais que c'était là depuis le début
en fait, je pense que ce que je regardais,
nous l'aurions récupéré de l'
autre côté en l'
inclinant peut-être un peu et là,
vous devenez
étranger,
merci
même s'il n'y a pas d'eau, ce
serait mieux s'il y avait de l'eau
ouais,
allez où bon euh
Saranac ou Indian
euh
je pense que samedi soir
parce qu'Indian Lake sera pareil
ça va être comme un petit lac comme
ça je vais faire un cercle autour de ceci d'
une manière ou d'une autre
celui-là
Encercle celui-là ouais oui s'il te plait ouais
ouais ils sont sympas
ils sont vraiment brillants
depuis très longtemps
tu en veux un oui encore une fois fais-le
deux fois ouais deux cercles par ici
essaie de ne pas t'approcher d'eux
pas positif nous sommes tous sur le même arbre
ouais je suis un chien lu  arbre,
c'était comme une petite couleur rouge,
veux-tu t'approcher, pouvons-nous nous rapprocher
ou est-ce que ça va ouais
parce que mon ombre
continue de m'allumer ouais, continue de regarder 20,
ok,
ok, nous allons
pouvoir nous rapprocher beaucoup plus
gros plans sur le cheesecake
c'est celui que nous survolons encore
une fois ouais
étranger étranger
garde le bruit est-ce que tu gardes le bruit
encore
je suis désolé
car nous avons par ici
la lumière est plutôt mauvaise